the author of the speed game my fast
times in basketball
is the former head coach of the los
angeles lakers pre-dating
pat riley man who won the 1980
championship here in los angeles
40 years ago 40 years obviously prior to
the latest
of the lakers he is paul westhead how
are you coach i'm doing fine chris how
are you i'm doing better for
talking to you so the speed game my fast
times in basketball
obviously uh we we do recall here in los
angeles your time of winning your first
championship here
in your first year as an nba head coach
uh
what do you think of what we just saw by
the lakers uh
and winning in 2020 in that bubble coach
yeah well i was uh watching uh like
most of the fans here hoping that they'd
pull it off
uh i i was really confident because they
were the better team and
when you have two superstars and lebron
and anthony davis you can lose a couple
but you're not going to lose the series
so
i was happy for them and i kind of
expected it
and what do you think of the state of
basketball today where we see a lot of
teams basically
shoot the three instead of the mid-range
jumper um and
somebody like yourself who is constantly
about the transition game
uh which is why you're talking about the
speed game um what do you make of the
current state of uh basketball in the
nba
yeah well i always was a proponent of
the quick shot we wanted to get
possession of the ball
and shoot within four to five seconds
we really didn't care uh the
range we take a running
you know driving slam dunk layup like
anthony davis does
on occasion or we take the outside three
but
uh there's much more outside shootings
today than there was 40 years ago uh
the three-point range is like fertile
ground now
everyone has to shoot them even centers
have to come out and shoot threes
so who's the best transition basketball
player you think that you ever saw
if not coached who's that yeah
that's a hard one you know
it's fine it's interesting i i won the
championship on the with the
la lakers with magic and kareem and
we were just an okay running team and we
were good but not great
uh when i was at loyola marymount
university you know
we were better at the running game with
players like hank gathers and beau
kimball
and then when i coached the the women in
the wnba
we were very good with uh diana taurasi
and a little point guard named kelly
miller who got the giant of the ball on
the break so
it kind of goes in phases and to have a
good individual on a fast break team
isn't enough uh you need five
plus people to buy into it or otherwise
you're going to get fired like i did in
a number of times paul westhead joining
me here on the rich eisen show and in
terms of
being let go from your position the the
conversation i mean it still lingers
here today
uh paul as you know about your tenure
here with the lakers
uh and jerry buss showing you the door
aft you're just a few games into a
season after you
uh got bounced by moses malone uh and a
couple years after you won it all with
magic johnson
what were the forces do you think behind
your firing do you talk about this in
your book
yeah i talk about it and and uh you know
i talked about the
the moment there were some things that
led up to the fire arena
we had played the night before in salt
lake city
and uh won a game
right at the end on a missed shot by
utah jazz and i was not happy with
the attention that magic johnson had
given
uh me and our team in that last moment
so
i talked him about it personally
uh and i unfortunately or would it for
whatever
a reporter saw me in another room
talking to magic and
asked magic and magic said well i don't
know if i can play here
so he was he was not happy with my
disapproval and the next day you know i
was fired by jerry buss but
you know in perspective i think it was a
little bit of
after this therefore because of this and
i think
the magic event uh was
part of three or four or five things
that i think
mr bus was not happy with so he finally
said we're gonna have to let you go
so uh and then obviously they turned to
one of your assistants what did you see
in pat riley when you hired him
paul yeah yeah it's interesting you know
i got the job
you know kind of early in the season i
was by myself for a couple weeks
it's kind of interesting uh uh we played
maybe eight for ten games with without
an assistant coach
uh now in the nba they have a dozen
assistant coaches
uh and the fellow who i asked to kind of
help me
chart some things was don ford who was
on the team
and didn't play much so i and and after
best three or four games ford said
you know i don't really like to do this
uh you're gonna have to get somebody
else
uh so then i brought in pat riley i knew
him i
had met him he traveled with us he was
the color man for
chick hearn and uh
i thought he would be you know very
helpful to me and he was
or it was a a timely pick on my part and
that certainly was true to form
so uh i mean it's kind of amazing that
again the lakers 40 years later after
your championship
just one another now with lebron james
and the guy who's
whose team uh the the opponent that they
beat was
has been put together by by pat riley
it's amazing how life works sometimes
paul right
yeah i mean that that cycle went full
for for pat you know from la to
to the knicks and then eventually to
miami so he
uh he's doing all the good things as as
a president that he
that he did with with the laker
franchise uh
but you know it what rings true
is that if you're going to win like we
just saw the lakers with lebron and
anthony davis
you must have two very exceptional
players uh
in the superstar category because i did
with kareem abdul-jabbar
and magic johnson so you have to have
that ingredient to then talk about well
you won and how did you do it well you
didn't do it without your two stars
so i guess there were super teams uh
well before super teams
in a way it just wasn't uh done by free
agency
pretty much right yeah i mean uh you
know
and if you recall in 1980 magic came in
as a rookie so
he kind of the lakers were a good team
you know
simmering simmering simmering i mean
kareem had been there and you know he
had performed well
but they just needed one more player to
get you
over the top and that's exactly what uh
magic brought to the team
it's kind of interesting the um magic
johnson goes down as the
the great assist passing guard you know
who had eyes behind his back because he
was so clever
when he played for our team in his first
year he
i would really categorize him as a power
forward
he he was getting to the rim he was
rebounding like like a big man and i i
think he was doing it
to show his teammates that you know i
want to work hard for you fellas so
uh accept me and then as his career went
on then
then he took over no doubt author of the
speed game my fast times in basketball
paul westhead here on the rich eisen
show
what are your recollections that you can
share with us of the day that hank
gathers
passed away coach yeah
that's a hard one uh you know it's it's
30 years now since that
uh moment and you know it's like
three seconds ago for me uh you know i
i we're at gerson arena in a playoff
game
to get into the ncaa and hank
makes a classic slam dunk on our fast
break which you know
like i alluded to anthony davis does now
turned around to get back on defense and
just around half court just collapsed
and fell
and never to recover and uh
i mean it's a moment frozen in time
the death of hank was
just more than hard to take it was
devastating and
to the tribute of the players they
eventually wanted to play in the
ncaa tournament kind of in honor of hank
gathers and
and they performed very well uh trying
to honor him
no doubt i remember they they bounced my
alma mater and it
it felt as again as a michigan fan
watching that game
it felt like a feta complete quite
frankly um
it felt like um you know certainly the
way that
in kimball shooting free throws like
hank and in his honor i'll never forget
that
um did you know beau was going to start
doing that when you started
yeah yeah he had said to us that he was
going to
the moment he got to the free-throw line
in any playoff game
and the first one was against new mexico
state and then michigan
uh he was going to shoot his first two
free throws
left-handed and on earth hank who the
background on this is
hank the year before led the country in
scoring
and rebounding he sure did not not an
easy feat
but he never was a very good free-throw
shooter so he said to me
in the springtime he said uh i'm gonna
work this summer on shooting
left-handed free throws and i i guess if
i was a more stern disciplined coach i
would have said
no i cannot deal with that yeah whatever
you want to do right
so he comes back and he's shooting it
the
true deform that he shot left-handed the
entire season
until the final game against portland
uh and beau picking that up to honor
hank
you know said well i'll shoot my first
two left-handed
uh so and and he made every one he shot
left-handed
sure he did it's kind of an interesting
tribute too well it was so
remarkable uh coach it was so remarkable
i i i do feel like it was just yesterday
um and the whole country was uh
feeling it feeling for you for
hank gathers family to who who did you
draw upon
what did you draw upon for foreign
well here's what happened to us i mean
me personally i drew on my wife cassie
and my four children and they
they kind of surrounded me with their
love and affection which
always helps to make it personal but
the players and myself
we fed off each other you know i kept
saying to them
do not do this you know
for hank hoping that he's going to
somehow miraculously
have you play better uh and they
they understood that they said no we
want to play
so that we can for two hours a day in
practice or in games
put our loss of hank aside
we just want to just do something that
we can forget for a moment for an hour
and in their forgetting the irony is
that they
didn't worry about winning or losing so
they just started playing
basketball kind of for fun so it was fun
to be around them for those
two hours when we would practice or have
the aims and
and when it ended uh then we had a good
time to the real world of
breathing for hank again and i know pj
carlos is somebody who's uh near and
dear to your heart
um you know uh you've been on his staff
and he and you have known each other for
a very long time
uh did beating michigan have a special
meaning for you
uh bouncing them after they won their
championship
yeah to be honest here honey i
saw the game that pj lost uh
at the buzzer uh i can still see the
ramil robinson
gets fouled and he makes the free throw
and wins the game
and uh pj
true to form uh
was very gracious and said well
it was the right call was john clarkety
who
made that call so
a year later yes we meet michigan
and i walk out to the start of the game
and who
is the official in the game oh john
no way i didn't know that oh yeah
and uh of course it wasn't a buzzer
peter no
no no that did not come down to free
throws that day paul i can recall that i
don't even know if it was a 19
possession game by the end quite frankly
i don't need to rub it in on me
one 149 116.
it wasn't even close and trust me
michigan wolverine fans were the only
people not rooting for you that day uh
on the planet
you know so yeah it was quite a day and
it was quite a victory for you and you
earned it you
you got it and um congrats on your book
the speed game my fast times in
basketball let's uh let's keep chatting
i really enjoyed this chat
thank you it was my pleasure thank you
that's paul westhead
the head coach champion head coach of
the in the nba and wnba
and his book where all books are
available right now paul west said the
speed game my fast times
in basketball hey you watched all the
way to the end thanks for that watch
more right here